on this episode Fredrick stops by
you ask
this is
ask Gary B
to 42-14 credit on to 414 episode yes
sir it's a lot of episodes a lot of
addresses how many episodes of your
shell have you know maybe like 16 five
seasons 12 episodes per season yeah but
you guys film a lot to get one episode
nine months precedes every film good for
nine months why because the lead time of
closing because of the all my deals take
like a month
you know the IT guys with this book all
right let's do this what is it - what
all right ready everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 214 of
the askgaryvee show
I'm pretty excited as a lot of you know
I do not watch television but when I
work in bed at 11:00 12:00 1:00 in the
morning my wife Lizzie has a couple of
shows she loves and this character right
here is one of her favorites some super
pumped about that
I like Lizzie you like her right yes yes
she is a keeper why don't you tell the
Vayner nation for the people that are
watching right now who do not know who
you are a little bit about yourself and
then we'll get into India's question
okay my name is Fredrik Eklund and I'm a
real estate agent in New York and the
show he's referring to his million
dollar listing New York on Bravo and
it's air tonight tonight and we'll get
this up Stefan if you will in a hustle a
little bit yeah
all right and how long have you been
doing it 13 years ski believe it feels
like I came to New York yesterday there
13 years and and tell me about the show
it's been on for five years now and yeah
I started filming six years ago and
everybody that I knew my family my
competitors Iran said I shouldn't do it
because reality TV is you know as an
agent you don't a show right friction
and certain things in your business and
I always believed that it'd be good from
a business and personal to so because
you thought it would get you exposure
yeah like I can't knock on enough doors
I can't send mailers out I mean how do
you get yourself out there to millions
of people as a real estate agent you
know especially me coming from Sweden
not knowing anyone yep not knowing the
language I didn't have any contacts or
and so what has been the global impact
on the business on your business being
number one in New York three years in a
row that's a that's a yes
yeah little clap a smart they hear a lot
of hyperbole for me no it's been amazing
I mean I don't know where the business
comes from you never know you can't
isolated you know yeah right I think you
need to be in all places so it's like
big on social media you're on television
you're people read about in New York
Times actually ads listings themself is
a great channel of advertisement yep and
so and actually you mentioned it you
know obviously we're at a very large
social media digital agency yeah how has
social been for you what do you what's
currently Fredrik are you have you
adapted snapchat are you know is it why
I'm scared about because I'm very old
I'm really scared about yeah thank you
look you're very hints I haven't I have
a baby face so like it's good for the
when I was young I look really young and
I'm looking like you know Connor young
yes ah no I'm scared of snap because I'm
gonna get addicted I know I'm gonna love
it so much and I have AG Lewis on the
show you know my friend yes he is
obsessed and he just runs around
snapping all the time I invited him to
my apartment and I could not have a real
conversation with him because you
snapped so so were you Twitter no why
was that such a visceral reaction I'm
not at want no Twitter is like you know
no I never I think you never did it no
not really I think I'm a photographer I
like photos yes I like that um and to
sell something which I do I sell real
estate I never saw somebody sell an
apartment over tweet okay
Instagram is good for that because you
have the you know people have bought
apartments off of tweets never happened
tell me one example so I have an example
I have a friend I did not but I have a
friend who bought an apartment all for
Twitter by tweeting so it's one you know
what's interesting you're talking about
push marketing right you're putting out
content when I think Twitter is
remarkable is you can literally search
everybody who tweets and my friend
tweeted out that he was looking for a
new home and real estate agents that
were listening reached out to him and
closed him on a multi-million dollar
home that's good that's good I just
think for me like listen I don't have a
lot of followers maybe like 130
40-something thousand followers in
Twitter I think that the the challenge
with Twitter is that people tweet and
you think that 140 thousand people going
to read it but then I read something I
was like 1% because he inform me
highways so fast and we agree with and
so who asked where as Instagram is a
little bit linear and you in face so
when you start snapchatting I am NOT
going to know are you willing to be on
the record you're saying you're never
gonna go on snapshot I want to be a
reoccurring character in my friends
snapchat account if you have one okay
I'll do like I don't wanna have my own I
need I need less social media not more I
think it's very addicted to me and I'm
like that personality wants to get into
something everything that I want to do I
want to do fully all like all in so like
I'm not gonna do what upload of snap
once a week I'm gonna become like Louise
and I'm gonna go to toilet them you know
want to be that and snap India let's get
into this show oh you've got videos
okay all videos so I'm gonna go yes here
we go oh who's that missus there's a fan
or a friend is is nice interested nope
pre-recorded is hi Gary my name is
Chiron srivatsa I am the president of
Telus properties for context we are the
fastest-growing real estate brokerage in
California with about 450 agents I'm 20
offices and my question to Gary is just
this how can a forward-thinking
brokerage like ours build a brand on
Facebook and Instagram that all our
agents can leverage to build their own
individual platforms thank you Gary
so I'll jump into this first one you can
add Frederick us because I've given a
lot of speeches at you know Remax and
and and Keller Williams and all these
organizations and wonder at that level
with a lot of offices they're always
trying to think about how they empower
their agents I mean this is a once in a
generation agent that comes along and
has that charisma level gets the
opportunity to be on television and it
has that up did you like that one since
I'm missing come on
so that's not that's not going to happen
for everybody so I think one of the
biggest ways that a company can enable
their agents that we see this in
insurance I see this in fast food where
people are franchisees is to create
content at scale in a hub that people
then have access to can pull from it and
then DJ the content so there's some
great platforms like percolate or you
can build something internally or you
can do an email blast but what I would
do is your company is I would invest in
video and I would
Besant photography produce content give
them assets and then training I think
one of the best things that I've seen
from people that have agents I've seen
this in insurance is they brought in the
forward thinkers and put them in front
of their users on a closed platform
livestreams QAS consulting opportunities
it's about education and assets and
that's what you want to empower so it's
an investment at the top level instead
of telling them or trying to get them to
do it force them to get there by
overwhelming them with value from the
highest level Wow it's good powerful
yeah so I mean my point of view social
media has always been to be as personal
as possible like I think that's a big to
answer this question maybe the big
challenge for real estate company any
kind of company is that they upload
photos only of their apartments or you
know I always give this example the
United Airlines who and I like United
Airlines I travel with them a lot but
they have like 88,000 emplyees but only
60,000 something followers an Instagram
they can't even get their own employees
and follow them because they upload
photos of the airplanes that's right so
like if you make it personal or bring
value hmm or bring value for example
when you're an airline if you actually
put out content around how to make
people travel better save money when
they travel skip lines like if you
actually brought utilitarian value for
social media is not that many successful
account if United Airlines posted photos
of people on airports meeting crying
loving hugging for using their vehicles
to meet after many years and writing
long personal emotional text then it
could be one of the most in your most
beautiful powerful Instagram accounts in
the world right and then they could sell
tickets indirectly my point is you see
that right behind you it's a book I
wrote a couple years ago called Jab Jab
Jab right hook it's what you're good
I'll give it to you but like it's what
you're describing which is put out
content that's valuable to them yeah Jab
Jab Jab build up equity and run then you
can ask for a transaction remind I have
like six hundred something thousand
followers I would say 10 to 20 percent
of my business comes from Instagram
honestly I launched my buildings from it
but it's because I also write emotional
text and people make fun of me because
I'm too emotional
like it's I'm a person and I'm you know
I'm an emotional person and then when I
finally upload something that's
realistic related there's more
stickiness different people pay
attention yes my career different than
yours
came from doing a wine show on YouTube
in the mid-2000s yes there was a point
where I was like wow and I was known as
like crazy in the wine world do you feel
like you've become a more extreme
version of your natural being because
this character like I always wonder like
have I changed be like do you feel like
you're exactly who you are five years
ago or do you think you're a more
extreme momentum version of yourself
because of what's at the end side done
five seasons last six years I'm actually
I mean it was I was never playing a
character because they don't tell us
what to do when the show is what I wish
it was scripted or if it's not right so
but if you look back if I look back on
the original season I was much harder
and much more I was kicking and
screaming and squealing and making crazy
faces actually like now I think on the
show I'm much calmer and I'm much more
because you've said it dirt yeah a
little bit but also kind of watching
myself so many years and just seeing
this like crazy character maybe call
messin cuz I'm happy I'm married you
know I know so um life change I don't
think it's only that way I think it's
the I also saw an episode where you
dressed up in character as Andy war so
free have you done that ever no oh my
god I disappear III was so free not to
be Fredrik anymore like I blacked out I
don't remember anything I will be well I
have an obsession too but he was so
amazing to like nah I mean I'm looking
forward to Halloween I'm gonna go all
out and they just like be someone else
that me any let's move this Oh Tom Barry
hey GV its TF checking in got a quick
question for you regarding real estate
what part of the home buying process do
you believe is broken and how could
technology that's solvent you know to me
very quickly and this is going off topic
I think paperwork I'm fascinated by time
there's a lot of startups that I've
invested and I invested a lot of
early-stage startups two of them and
I've recently invested in one helps
people submit for adoption in 17 minutes
instead of seven years another one is
for will
it helps you produce a will in an hour
that is very legit versus all the time
and money
I think the paperwork process mortgage
process I mean like these so you know
the creative the the vision you showing
something that's humans that's not
technology but the stuff like when you
know I bought a place Audi's signing for
an hour like that's not interesting to
me like there has to be a better way
that technology can solve getting a
experts opinion where is the market
going why is this a new neighborhood
that's the creative that's the magic
that doesn't get replaced the commodity
does we don't write letters put them in
the envelope by a stamp like it put it
we just set you know technology fixes
the inefficiencies and I think the
inefficiency that is commoditized is the
paperwork process of mortgages because I
did the co-op board packages and there's
600 pages and they're like you know to
your point they take months to complete
there's a way to like dip yeah but I
mean when I start when I started um this
was 13 years ago and that's like how old
I am the listings were 35 39 the
listings were coming in via fax no this
is true there was no this existed there
was no near council fax service get my
email service right and they get fax
people offers I used to watch the
freakin fax
every morning I came to the office and
got my jam and with papers because the
listings were coming in and I was
sitting circling my first year these
listings in the New York Times to take
buyers and then I was like the first
person I think they had a blackberry or
blueberry whatever we call it with a
wheel do you remember that yes I came
from London from that from The Wall
Street Board for those hedge fund guys
there yes and if people thought I was
crazy because I could answer in real
time I just it's funny in 13 years like
how much it's changed but in in the real
estate world what happen is everybody
was saying the real estate agent is
going to be eliminated there's no need
for it because now you have CDs in all
these systems and Zillow but what
happened is that the big real estate
agents are getting big bigger than ever
because that skill matters that skill
matters what has happened is and this is
and this is actually is a very good
point a lot of you you're Tech and
entrepreneur driven everybody always
says this is going to be dead nothing
dies what happens is the B that's right
the B and C and D players lose and the a
players take up more because what
technology does
is it takes out commodity and commodity
is usually the only value prop that the
C and D player brings the table yeah
that was interesting
that's good I like this we're getting a
I feel this somewhat I feel the real
estate angel in the room Dan that's in
yard well we're moving to Hudson Yards
our office in about yeah thanks I work
on some of the most incredible real
estate developments in New York City
including Hudson Yards Gary I heard
you're moving your offices over there
from Park Avenue South so I'd love to
hear why you decided to make the move
and Frederick from a residential angle
I'd love to hear what about Hudson Yards
you're the most excited about I'll let
you go first cuz it's far more
interesting I mean I mean what's the buy
no I mean I answer the question I'm
obsessed with New York I mean like my my
husband said he makes fun of me he's
angry at me because I say New York is
the biggest lobster in my life honestly
he's no I think it's happening like the
new the new new downtown which is the
old financial district
yes used to be Wall Street which is not
financial at all um the Seaport is
blowing up Hudson Yards they're all
equally do you think if you think the
Hudson Yards thing is gonna be a big big
deal oh it's major it's like 22 acres of
parks is like 39 skyscrapers it's
unbelievable the retail and its location
if you look at the map simpler Jersey
boy is great I just want to know but
it's perfectly located you're close to
the park gross admit I mean it's but
it's still close to the water and the
infrastructure that the building is
going to be incredible the point I you
know it's not so much the love for
Hudson yard it's going to be great it's
the love for New York always turning
over always changing I can't keep up
with it no one can keep up with it so
their minds much more practical Steven
Ross who's building that project as my
business partner and a part owner of
vaynermedia because I want to buy the
New York Jets one day and he owns the
Miami Dolphins so I want to be in that
ecosystem you can become a Jets fan good
and you know and we're growing so fast I
needed to be in a home where we could
grow from within and plopping ourselves
over there I thought was a very good
idea Plus Jewish holidays getting to
Jersey just scooting right into Lincoln
Tunnel I'll save myself an extra hour
for for a business meeting so I like
that cool in do and you're gonna get an
amazing view I'm assuming cuz they're
all like great well yeah I mean I mean
I'm I created two offices one to look at
Jersey where I grew up to like be home
you know
that's my place and to looking at
Madison Square Garden because I'm a huge
Knicks fan yeah what are you an expand
can you be an expand
say yes yes let's move it Harold Harold
greetings gentlemen my name is Harold
Alliston real estate broker sales
trainer motivational speaker my question
to you Fredrick is in the early years of
your career how did you build and
continually contact your database and
now that the show so popular and giving
you many more opportunities how are you
guys managing that thank you appreciate
you that in the beginning on the very
beginner McCarrick like once again I was
sat all by myself I had no one helping
me no more no one mentoring me did you
work at a firm yeah very small firm with
six agents in West Chelsea I came off
the shrimp boat not knowing anything not
only to come here oh you just knew yeah
I knew because I came here on I was ten
and I honestly teach it I was so in love
with the energy and the neon and the
danger and the not so much any money but
the P the whole thing you know I'm come
from Sweden it's very calm and beautiful
and old and know my family still there I
love it I come back but I mean New York
you know not so for 20 years I was
frustrated not living here so I came in
the finally BAM nearly use your National
place I was by myself learning the craft
yeah I think you know I never really had
a database to answer questions I never
you know and I need to be better at that
I don't what I do is I see every single
person that I meet including you gonna
buy your next apartment for me as a
potential like Commission chick walking
around with little four legs unsigned
right exactly as we are no you so every
person is it's an opportunity so it's
like I'm a big one at my first open
house all these people that keep me and
I just turned them over into new clients
and this listing inventory I'm so scared
I know in my heart this is the last
month my prime it's over last year was
the best here that's how I feel do you
feel like that always yes and I wake up
every morning like you're only as good
as your last bath so I need ah and like
always expect well it's the funny the
[ __ ] love it
okay good I want to grow too I just
gotta figure out how I'm gonna say grow
like I gotta find my no but I but you
know what I think that's right I think
you know to me I never think anything
I've accomplished yesterday means any
for tomorrow you're never cool in the
last deal or video I mean 100% 100% you
yes Lenny Lenny looks fired up hey Gary
hey Fred GK India hope everything as
well I'm so excited to be part of the
show I hopefully make this but I am
interested is it better to focus on
branding or better to focus on
transactions when you're starting out as
a new agent in the luxury market in New
York City oh my god
Lenny the man I mean both but I mean you
by the way I'm gonna stop you okay good
that's the [ __ ] answer that's the
[ __ ] answer what people don't
understand is branding and sales he's
like because he looks at me as a human
check running around and he wants to be
transactional he's gonna win in the same
way that I think sales matters so much
but much like him and he accomplished
his way I think what has made me
successful at the level that we're at is
branding and branding what's remarkable
is you know his charisma and that moment
time and I don't know why they picked
them or what happened is serendipity a
lot of those things he had that
opportunity at a huge scale the fact
that all of you have the opportunity
make a video and be on this and out
hundreds of thousands of people will see
you the Internet has changed everybody's
opportunity for brand but selling is
hustle yeah
selling gonna back it up with the state
I mean with the deals too but I mean my
advice anyone new and anything
especially like real estate of sales is
to be notic century because you get you
as long as authentic has to be genuine
right be you like I was so nervous when
I first came here I clocked up myself
and I wasn't the guy that you yeah right
because I thought if I told people who I
was and gay and came from sweet high
kick all things that I do today I would
never be hired or fired all those things
so so you understand like now reality TV
in some ways taught me that the hard way
because you know I'm allowed to be this
crazy guy so anyway so in the beginning
if it's 60 thousand sales real estate
agents in Manhattan just be you and own
it everybody loves to see somebody's
authentic that's my you know there's a
nuts branding this piece if I'm gonna
make you do a little work which will
make this episode come out a little
later but before 9:00 p.m. Eastern
I want you to show some clips I want you
actually use what you we have all these
video interns now I want you to show
four or five clips from episode 12 19 22
of it Wine Library TV I was running a
very large wine shop and I had these
very high-end clients who were spending
four or five hundred thousand dollars a
year on wine so think about that and the
first 40 or 50 80 actually another
number the first 80 episodes of my wine
show I was very reserved hey guys it's
me Gary Vaynerchuk Wine Library TV hello
everybody and welcome to a wonderful
episode of Wine Library TV I am your
host Gary Vaynerchuk hello everybody and
welcome to an action-packed episode of
Wine Library TV I'm your host Gary
Vaynerchuk really yes reserve now
correct well that's why I'm jumping
everywhere like I the show was doing
extremely well
it was early YouTube the first year of
YouTube it was starting to get going and
I was like wait a minute if they think
I'm entertaining now if they knew what I
was really like right and I just said
you know screw it after episode 80 I'm
like you know what I just jumped off the
clip I said look I'm gonna be me I may
lose 10 I'm gonna gain a hug and you
can't please don't and it's a better way
to living anyways right Rick I know you
need to run I gotta go take the stage at
itok you just gave I want you to do a
very important thing here okay every
guest gets to ask the question of the
day so now you get to ask the tens of
thousands of people that are watching
this a question of the day any question
you want answered it's a good
opportunity gets an insight you can ask
a random question knock yourself out
what is your question in the day well my
question of the day would be like it's
all about being driven to ask yourself
what is your true drive is the money is
it Fame is a charity is it your mom
whatever it is that you need to put that
or not post it on your mirror brushing
your teeth the other one is the goal
what is your goal the exact is it the
first million is it once again to buy
your mom a house is it to buy a new car
whatever it is what is the goal
visualize put that on a stick or two on
your bathroom mirror when you're washing
brushing your teeth of you put do those
two things you're going to be super
successful ask yourself those two
questions my friend continued success
thank you you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them sup guys hope
you enjoyed the show please do I get to
link it up anywhere is it like in here
or is it down below is it in print or is
it in my video no it'll be yeah it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that